vous voyez bien qu'aristote est
minuscule et du coup tout ce qui sort de
son corps est minuscule sais pas si vous
voyez venir s'il fait nuit lorsque je le
sors et bien j'ai du mal à voir ces
merdes
j'ai besoin de la lampe de torches de
mon iphone pour les voir distinctement
avant de les ramasser
alors je sais bien c'est bizarre comme
accroche quel est donc le rapport avec
la rédaction d'un argument dissertation
je vous rassure vous regardez bien la
bonne vidéo
regardez là jusque vous et vous serez
rédiger un argument de dissertation à la
perfection
[Musique]
avant de vous expliquer le sens de mon
accroche bizarre je vous invite à vous
inscrire à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie qui vous explique tout de a
à z avec des schémas et des exemples
vous pouvez vous aussi le recevoir soit
en cliquant sur le lien qui s'affiche en
haut à droite soit sur celui qui est
dans la description de la vidéo
inscrivez-vous et vous m'en direz des
nouvelles alors quel est le sens de mon
accroche ce que je veux vous dire c'est
que sans la lumière je ne serais pas
capable d'identifier l'objet matériel
dans l'espace avant de pouvoir le saisir
voyez la lampe torche de mon iphone est
bien un argument c'est sa lampe torche
mais dans le monde des idées
le mot argument vient du grec argos qui
signifie blanc clair ça veut dire qu'un
argument sert à apporter de la clarté
donner un argument s'est appuyé sur le
bouton d'une lampe torche
l'interlocuteur doit y voir plus clair
dans notre propos afin de mieux saisi à
vos idées qui sont des objets
intellectuelle donc un argument favorise
la compréhension de votre discours en
dissertation les arguments sont les
phrases qui permettent aux correcteurs
de comprendre votre réponse à la
problématique
ce sont les premières phrases des
paragraphes du développement celle qui
présente les idées directrices de votre
raisonnement
or ces traces sont cruciales si elles
sont ratés le correcteur n'y verra rien
dans votre raisonnement et vous vous
ramasserez une sale note
alors comment rédiger un argument de
dissertation efficace comment éclairer
vos idées avec une lumière puissante
dans le monde des idées
vous ne pouvez pas utiliser un iphone je
vous donne ma formule en six points
regardez bien cette vidéo jusqu'au bout
et vous passerez un niveau supérieur en
dissertation vous allez gagner
facilement des points dès votre prochain
devoir aller premier point pour rédiger
un argument dissertation à la perfection
[Musique]
je voulais dire la première phrase du
paragraphe qui présente l'argument cette
phrase est la plus importante donc il
est capital que le correcteur plus la
comprendre facilement comment faire eh
bien il faut déjà qu'elle soit courte
en effet les études expérimentales sur
la lecture montre que les phrases les
plus courtes sont statistiquement les
mieux comprises et les mieux mémoriser
en présentant votre argument avec une
phrase courte vous permettez donc aux
correcteurs de comprendre l'idée
directrice du paragraphe mais aussi de
la retenir pour lire la suite de la
dissertation maintenant comment en
pratique rédiger une phrase courte
premier critère c'est bien sûr le nombre
de mots essayer d'en écrire moins de 12
et tant que vous êtes en dessous de 15
ça va le second critère c'est le nombre
de verbes conjugués limitez vous à un
seul verbe conjugué vous allez rédiger
ce qu'on appelle une phrase simple
alors maintenant je vous donne des
exemples lisez cet argument le travail
et déshumanisant lorsqu il transforme
l'individu en esclaves ou lorsqu il
prive le travailleur de toutes les
possibilités que sa vie d'homme lui
offre la phrase n'est pas efficace parce
qu'elle est trop longue
elle comporte 24 mans et parce qu'il ya
quatre verbes conjugués lise et
maintenant cet argument le travail
s'avère déshumanisant pour l'individu la
phrase est efficace parce qu'elle est
courte elle comporte six mots et parce
qu'il y à un seul verbe conjugué donc
retenez bien un argument dissertation
efficace c'est une phrase courte avec un
seul verbe conjugué allez on passe au
deuxième point que la phrase soit court
ça ne suffit pas à garantir qu'on la
comprenne facilement viser par exemple
celle ci l'idiosyncrasie se substitue
d'elle-même à l'ontologie elle ne fait
que six mots elle ne comporte qu'un seul
verbe conjugué et pourtant je ne sais
pas vous mais moi je n'ai pas comprises
en plus d'être courte la phrase qui
présente l'argument dissertation doit
donc être clair clair ça veut dire qu'on
voit immédiatement l'idée de l'argument
comme si elle était éclairé par un spot
en tant que lecteur on n'a aucun effort
à faire ont saisi l'idée instantanément
mais comment écrire une phrase clair en
pratique vous devez faire attention à
deux choses la première c'est d'exprimer
une seule idée pas deux pas trois une
seule idée bien identifiable la seconde
chose c'est d'éviter autant que possible
le jargon les termes techniques et donc
de préférer les mots de la langue
d'ordinaire je reprends mon exemple le
travail s'avère déshumanisant pour
l'individu
cette phrase exprime clairement une
seule idée les effets déshumanisants du
travail
les mots travail s'avérer individus ne
pose aucun problème
après le terme déshumanisant est un peu
technique mais on comprend quand même
facilement l'idée c'est perdre ce qui
fait de nous un être humain je pourrais
éventuellement clarifier l'argument en
écrivant le travail des pouilles
l'individu de sa dignité humaine mais
bon je trouve que la première version
est déjà assez clair donc retenez bien
un argument dissertation efficace c'est
une phrase très clair dont on comprend
l'idée instantanément allez on passe au
troisième point
[Musique]
une des erreurs que commettent beaucoup
de lèvres en dissertation c'est qu'il se
contredisent leur a parlé du plan thèse
antithèse synthèse
donc ils durent croient qu'ils peuvent
affirmer une chose puis son contraire
premier souci avec cette manière de
faire c'est l'incohérence
vous ne pouvez pas dire le tee shirt de
romain et noir puis le tee shirt de
romain et bleu parce qu'un t-shirt ne
peut pas avoir deux couleurs en même
temps vous êtes en train de vous
contredire
second souci avec cette manière de faire
c'est que vous affirmer avec certitude
une chose fausse
vous dites que vous êtes sûr que mon
t-shirt et bleu harkis les noirs comment
pouvez vous éviter à la fois de vous
contredire et de défendre des idées
fausses en vous exprimant avec nuance
n'écrivez pas le tee shirt de romain et
bleu mais le tee shirt de romain semble
bleus cela a deux avantages
cela vous permettra tout d'abord de dire
plus tard que sous un autre angle avec
une autre lumière est bien là le t-shirt
semble noah et le second avantage c'est
que vous vous donnez le droit à l'erreur
vous précisez bien en employant le verbe
semblait qu'il s'agit de l'apparence du
t-shirt le tee-shirt barré bleu mais il
peut très bien être noah et si les noirs
vous n'aurez pas commis une erreur vous
n'aurez pas défendu une idée fausse je
reprends mon exemple le travail s'avère
déshumanisant pour l'individu là ma
phrase manque de modération parce que le
travail n'est pas toujours déshumanise
est ce que le travail de néma
déshumanisant crois pas non est-ce qu
être médecin c'est déshumanisant bien
sûr que non en réalité c'est un certain
type de travail qui est déshumanisé
par exemple celui des enfants qui
étaient ouvriers dans les usines pendant
la révolution industrielle
je dois donc corriger la formulation de
l'argument il vaut mieux écrire
le travail peut s'avérer déshumanisant
pour l'individu grâce au verbe pouvoir
je montre que l'idée a valeur
d'hypothèses que ce n'est pas une vérité
absolue
cet argument témoigne de ma maturité
intellectuelle
je ne prétends pas détenir la vérité
avant même d'avoir réfléchi au problème
intellectuel de la dissertation mais
j'avance hypothèse par hypothèse comme
un scientifique
depuis cet argument me laisse la liberté
d'examiner l'idée opposé le caractère
épanouissant du travail plus tard dans
un autre paragraphe de la même
dissertation donc retenez bien un
argument dissertation et efficace est
emprunt
nuance point numéro cap
[Musique]
si vous avez déjà regardé certaines de
mes vidéos ou lui certains de mes
articles sur la dissertation alors vous
connaissez probablement déjà ce point je
répète souvent que le but de la
dissertation ce n'est pas de réciter son
cours n'est plus au collège la
dissertation est un exercice de
réflexion et d'expression écrite donc
les connaissances ne sont pas la
priorité
c'est pour cette raison qu'un argument
dissertation ne doit comporter aucune
référence ou connaissances un argument
c'est un élément de réponse à la
problématique c'est une hypothèse
issu de votre propre réflexion sur le
sujet de la dissertation donc inutile de
mentionner un auteur un ouvrage et plus
généralement de mobiliser une quelconque
référence
je reprends mon exemple le travail peut
s'avérer déshumanisant pour l'individu
pas de référence donc la phrase respecte
le quatrième point en l'état il ne
fallait pas écrit par exemple marthe
affirme que le travail peut s'avérer
déshumanisant donc
retenez bien pas de références ou de
connaissance dans un argument de
dissertation on passe au 5ème point
[Musique]
si je vous demande leur vous n'allez pas
me répondre
il pleut ou alors il faut aller
consulter non parce que quand on vous
pose une question vous répondait de
manière pertinente bien c'est pareil en
dissertation on vous pose une question
la problématique donc vous devez y
répondre précisément vous ne devez pas
répondre à côté
or un argument c'est un élément de
réponse à la problématique
il doit donc absolument être pertinents
le mot pertinence vient du verbe latin
pertinents qui signifie atteindre votre
argument doit donc atteindre sa cible
c'est à dire répondre à la question
posée en pratique vous devez surtout
donner l'impression de la pertinence
parce que le correcteur ali la copie
très rapidement comment donner
l'impression que vous touchez juste en
reprenant le mot clé du sujet ou une
alternative et en renvoyant à la
formulation du sujet l'objectif c'est
que le correcteur face instantanément la
connexion entre votre argument et
l'énoncé je reprends mon exemple le
sujet et travailler s vivre mieux et mon
argument et le travail peut s'avérer
déshumanisant pour l'individu le mot
déshumanisant renverse le sens du mot
clé du sujet qui est l'adverbe mieux 6
et déshumanisant c'est pas mieux
c'est pire et puis le nom comme un
travail c'est la notion clé du sujet en
conclusion il est impossible de croire
que mon argument est hors sujet bien au
contraire tel qu'il est rédigé il touche
en plein dans le mille
donc retenez bien un argument de
dissertation efficace doit créer une
forte impression de pertinence en
reprenant les mots clés du sujet et en
renvoyant plus globalement à la
formulation du sujet allez sixième et
dernier point
[Musique]
votre argument dissertation n'est pas
seul au monde
il s'intègre dans une structure il ya
une place et un rôle ça on doit
normalement le comprendre facilement en
lisant votre dissertation
mais si on peut ne pas avoir à faire
l'effort de le comprendre c'est encore
mieux qu'est ce que je veux dire
eh bien je veux dire que vous devez
accompagner le lecteur par la main
c'est une image hein donc vous devez
accompagner une lecteur par la main afin
qu'ils ne se perdent pas dans les étapes
de votre raisonnement
ça c'est l'idée du sixième point vous
allez voir que c'est très simple en
pratique
en pratique vous pouvez vous contenter
d'indiquer dans la formulation de
l'argument le lien qui existe entre
l'idée de cet argument est celle du
précédent
est ce que l'idée de cet argument est
une conséquence de celle du pré saison
est ce que c'est à cause
est-ce qu'elle l'a prolongé bref ne
laissez pas le correcteur chercher le
lien
dites le lui clairement avec un mode
liaison je reprends mon exemple le
travail peut s'avérer déshumanisant pour
l'individu là je ne donne aucune
indication
si l'idée de l'argument renchérit par
rapport à la précédente je pourrais
écrire
le travail peut même s'avérer
déshumanisant pour l'individu si l'idée
est une conséquence de la précédente je
pourrais écrire
le travail peut ainsi s'avérer
déshumanisant pour l'individu si les
deux ils s'opposent le travail peut
cependant s'avérer déshumanisant pour
l'individu etc
retenez donc bien un argument de
dissertation efficace indique clairement
sa place dans la structure
intellectuelle et en pratique il suffit
de connecter et l'idée de l'argument
avec celle de l'argument précédent avec
un beau liaison
[Musique]
ça y est vous connaissez ma formule pour
rédiger un argument dissertation à la
perfection
je vous rappelle les six points rédigé
d'une phrase courte très clair nuance et
sans aucune référence aux connaissances
reprenez le mot clé du sujet est renvoyé
à la formulation du sujet et enfin
introduisez un mot liaison pour
connecter l'argument au précédent voilà
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plu et qu'elle boostera utile si vous
avez des questions n'hésitez pas à
laisser un commentaire
je vous rappelle que vous pouvez vous
inscrire pour recevoir mon cours
gratuits de méthodologie de la
dissertation soit en cliquant sur le
lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite soit
en utilisant celui qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo je suis
romain je suis toujours avec mon fidèle
aristote et vous étiez sur 1000 et de
culture générale rappelez vous vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour rédiger un super arguments de
dissertation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]